区目白ハード社長ですね皆さんパソコンとで触る人いますでしょうかまぁ普通ことが
入ったら授業とかでパソコン方からしたことある人を言うと思うんですけども
キーボードのタイピングってあるじゃないですか姉あの誰かのを見ているとき打ち
間違いを見ると
とベリーラっとしませんかそんな感覚になってる人あんまりいないと思うんですよね
やっぱり誰かがミスたら内町が入っていたんだ時と場合によってはちょっとイラッて
することがあるんですけどもその私はですね
ゴッチさんという中に萩堂だの編集をちょっと教えておりまして寝ぼけばどんなの編集
するときぼっちさんが交通を見ながら編集していろいろ教えたりしてるんですけども
もし仮に僕が押せ得られる
立場だったら教えてくれる人が編集でタイピングミス打ちたい文字を打とうとしてるの
に間違えてるのを見るとちょっとイラッとしとだと思って大家たその内町で何回やら
れるとキレるのかちょっと実験してみたいと思いますなぜターゲット殴った自称優しい
んで今時れたところ見たことないんですけどそんな彼でも打ち間違いがあまりに多
すぎると颯助
偉大な人靴入れると思うんで本人にはとても申し訳ないんですけどもこれも検証で
果たして人間はパソコンで何回キーボードの打ち間違いをされるとキレるのか検証して
いきたいと思いますではないかと思います
今日私が教えましょう宜しくお願いしますします
もしちゃいましょうお願いします勉強です
神通動画んですけどクリスマス j が起きますよね上のほうが1戦ゲームがいますっ
て
左端に揃えますそれに伴って左側ちょっとひるんで
ティっ写メ画面もちょっと means ロス全斗煥 to do
はい
ni
持っていた
持った
日
[音楽]
ん
小さい橋梁ですか
すいません
ん
競争ですからめっちゃ今一つやってまず
めっちゃ最強に付いたよ
いやマットバッグバッグって最後に下げはい禁酒
ん
パトラスですね
ぴずなったんです傷ならずはお大事なん
あった
ドロシーのでいつものいつもの解散もポスト
[音楽]
ハイソなのですで質問月に出せば方を見やすいかなったと言って画面
グッ
なんですけどねちゃいましたおやすみ
ポップことが作れます
[音楽]
なんですけど
うん大介打ったんですけどねブーブー
4月さんからさっとじゃあねなんかの空を求刑してくれたかけていただいて
[音楽]
暗い長さが得てきたチーズ位
いいんですか
暗い
第一大事です
まっちー男性カブ祭りです寒い july スピッツプロボックス
スカラボななヒーローと庁舎変化を持ちづらい
pr
ます
いっ
こんな感じですねです
一つ
バージョンバージョン
そりゃたふうに混ざりか中身ん
おばあちゃん車会社
[音楽]
ブーバーし
dee
はしまーす今不良ぶってんじゃないかぐるぐる回しますも
[音楽]
padi りゃー
サッカーすかー
踊ってもんじそうですはぁっ
前は動くん
マガシャ回しま
そうあ pro 4
気しないああ
2月と聞きながらも指摘はそ
[音楽]
ん
回すって文字打つ突破口ですか
ていた
絶対じゃ何が簿ビオルを塗ってせますよって
ん
何か良い2打ってはの強化
流します彼らの腕てるじゃないですかこんな奴はどこ行っています
サッカーサッカーやってませんケースで僕祝絵ですから
[音楽]
4日
サンリオピューロランドを出てるんですよえっ
th
[音楽]
ん
で
あった
ん
消えろー
[音楽]
me
バッハ
家や外で打つの違いなんかいいしたらキレるのかぁはぁそういうことか
全部た運送に突っ込む市南ダンスが入ったありがとうございます
俺ゆんかい
俺ゆん回キほどの家畜なったかなと思ってるんだからちょっと責任が感じてきたのを
待った若干
にゃんっているんですよブナコサービスギターかなと言うとは設定ややばい弁償だと
思ってちょっと本気で焦ってて
でも楽しくなんか印象覚えたいなと思った結果が動く読み上げる